Yes. Now we introduce Sebastian Müller
to the stage. He's going to talk about
visualization.
And what's interesting is that Sebastian
told me that he's um worked for quite
some time or for two decades on
visualization and graph visualization.
And in the past three to four years um
he's seen the need to visualize
knowledge graphs or ontologies or any
kind of connected data um as a as a new
field or something that's um um gaining
a lot of popularity among his customers.
And this is really important for any
kind of uh stakeholder work or subject
matter expert work that you would want
to do when you uh work with your
knowledge graphs to to take it out from
from the abstract code and things that
um seem very unapproachable for
nontechnical people and um make sense
out of it. So I'm really excited and u
to hear what Sebastian has to tell us
about best practices for visualizing
graphs and um let's welcome him. Thank
you.
>> Thank you Katalina. Uh thank you for
this very nice introduction. So my talk
is about visualizing connected data.
It's not specifically targeted at at
knowledge graphs, but knowledge graphs
lend lend themselves very well for
visualization as you will hopefully see
after or during my presentation. So, um
we already got this very nice
introduction from her. So, here's here's
my social media contact data if you want
to contact us and um please feel free to
do so. And we also do have a booth
outside there. So if you want to know
more uh about how we might be able to
help you with your visualization
challenges, drop by our booth after this
talk.
So um this is going to be about how to
get um from the left hand side to the
right hand side to go from simple
textbased visualizations or
representations of knowledge or these
super complex graphs that you may know
to the ones that are more useful
actually. So how do you get from the
left hand side to the right hand side?
Uh let's start with the why. Why should
we visualize data at all? That's because
we as humans are inherently visual
creatures. It it has been said that we
can process visual information more than
60,000 times faster than text. I don't
think that you can like transfer this
factor from looking at a table to
looking at a diagram, but at least the
tendency is pretty clear. And I'll show
you an example. So here's here's some a
number of triples showing a data set
about a relationship in a royal family.
And here's a visualization of that or a
simil similar data set. And now let's
look at why this visualization might be
better or easier for you to understand
than the textual representation. So at
the top we have QE2 and we see there's
several layers and each of these layers
they represent a different um
generation. So there there's always the
children below that and then we have
color coding. So there's Prince Phillip
married to Queen QE2 and all the gens
are blue and the ladies are in pink and
the relationships are also co colorcoded
so it's easy to distinguish between them
and I'm sure by now some of you have
spotted that there's a mistake in there
and that was only or mostly because of
the visualization. If you look at the
text and had to find that same error in
the text, I'm sure you wouldn't have
been able to find that so quickly. So
obviously Megan Markle at the top right
is is not correct there. And you see
that because if she's in the wrong
layer, the color pattern doesn't match
up. And there's this awkwardly long edge
going all the way down up from Prince
Harry up to Meghan Markle.
And
the other way around, it would be even
more difficult. Consider that in the
textual visualization, there would be
one of these links missing. I bet you
would never be able to find them just by
reading the text. But by looking at the
visualization, it's super easy to find.
But visualization is not just about
speed. It's really about insight. So you
can make use of these factors to
increase the performance of your users
for understanding the data. So it's not
about quicker seeing the same
information but getting more of the
information out of it in the same time.
So these are some of the visual uh the
advantages of visualization. Obviously
visualizations really shine at revealing
patterns and relationships. So they help
you to reveal connections to show
clusters or to find outliers or see the
flows or follow the paths and understand
dependencies. Something that you can't
do with text. Text is basically a 1D
representation of the data and you
probably need to like read it from from
top to bottom. Whereas in a diagram, in
a visualization, it's inherently
multi-dimensional even if it's just
printed on a 2D uh visualization because
well, you can always uh branch off to
another dimension by edges and
relationships.
So with visualization you can really
simplify those complex structures and
you can represent many data points in a
diagram and make them easy to understand
for your users.
But there's more more than this. They
are much more intuitive to navigate. So
things like even with a static
visualization, things like exploring the
diagram are are easier to do and and
they the mapping from the from the
action of searching through the diagram
or zooming into into a spec specific
part of the diagram is much more natural
because well you can literally move
closer to the diagram and inspect a
certain part. And later on if you add
interactivity of course this maps a lot
better than with a static visualization
or static representation like a textual
representation.
So to sum it up um it's much more easy
to communicate insights to a pretty
diverse audience um using
visualizations.
So when should you be using
visualization? If it's mostly about
connected data. So if the the topics
that you're discussing is where the
connectivity is at its core. So if if
it's really the patterns that you're
interested in or that you need to
understand or that your users need to
understand then using visualization is a
really good um thing. Um take for
example knowledge graphs. So if there's
if you want to understand whether there
are two entities whether they are linked
and there's no direct link between those
two entities but there might be multiple
indirect relationships in between. So
why are multiple hops then with with
visualization you can much more easily
communicate this fact.
Of course you can still use other
visualizations and you should for from
other data other types of data. So you
should be using tables or bar charts or
lists and all those things that Excel
provides
in several situations. Of course for
simple or low volume data, but also if
the data that you're showing is mostly
numerical data, high volume numerical
data or even just single precise values.
But even if the answers that you want to
convey or want to show to your users are
in a way a simple graph structure like a
really trivial or always a really really
trivial structure like a chain or a star
where there's just one element in the
center and many items connected to it.
It's probably better to use a list
because in a way that's just a disguised
list.
Use visualization when the complex
relationships appear in your data.
So let's take a look at um how
visualizations work in practice. So um
many of us if we create manual
visualizations we use the whiteboard to
transfer the data to a diagrams. But of
course we have computers nowadays and we
can use computers for automatic
visualization.
But computers help us to work with
massive amounts of of visualizations of
of data to create huge visualizations.
But I consider these pretty basic
visualizations.
What are basic visualizations? They
mostly consist of just simple shapes
like circles or rectangles and are
connected by by lines and they they look
pretty pretty much very nice and and I
would probably put them behind my desk
on my back and watch them and say, "Oh,
that's a nice visualization."
But they are not really helpful, not
really useful.
Um, and that's because of different
aspects of it. They mostly have these
pretty arbitrary layouts that really
don't convey much information. They show
or they try to show closeness between
elements in the graph, but they can be
pretty wrong about this. Consider that I
could just rotate this image like by 30
degrees or mirror it horizontally or I
could even like remove 30% of the edges
in there or nodes and you wouldn't see a
difference. I mean, they mostly look the
same. No matter whether it's a social
network or a website network or a bra
neurological brain map, whatever, they
always always look the same. And
sometimes I argue that the information
like on the bottom right is probably the
better visualization. Just showing the
number of nodes and the edges is
probably a better visualization. And
even more so if it's a static display,
great for hanging on the wall, but not
so useful. Let's go to the more
sophisticated ones. So, how can we do
better? How can we uh change the
visualization to get to make it more
useful?
Um,
in order to create these, we really need
to first understand the needs of our
users. What what questions are they
asking? What's the use case they have
for looking at the data? Why are they
looking at the data? What what do they
want to know? And even more so um what
should the answers look like? How should
we present the information to them in
the best possible way?
So the first advice sounds pretty simple
but it's actually really hard to get
right and thing is um you should keep
the visualization nice and simple and
small. Um,
so you can use techniques like filtering
to focus on just the information that
the users want
for this. This takes a lot of time and
but gets you probably the most value out
of it. Focus on the answer. Keep it
small.
How can you do this? Because your
database contains thousands of elements.
So and sometimes those elements are they
are stored in a way that it suits the
database well or that you can optimize
the queries or that in the way it's just
for historical reasons the way the data
is stored in your database. But that's
not the way that you want to see the
data uh being represented to your users.
So here's here's some ideas for you to
project your data from your database
into a useful visualization.
First example is is hierarchies. So um
consider the right examp uh the left
example on the left um where there's a
hierarchy depicted by edges the way that
it's probably stored in a database like
in a parent off or child off
relationship.
Um it's maybe not the best way to
represent this in a in a visualization.
much much much more intuitive for most
users is to put these into recursively
nested boxes and later on with
interactivity you can actually
intuitively expand and collapse these
boxes to to drill down into the
information. So consider mapping the
information from the database to the
diagram. It's important to understand
that you don't need to change your data
in the in the database for this. You can
do this on the level of the
visualization only. Another idea is to
show transitive relationships. So if if
you the user is only really interested
in the two end points of a chain, but
there's no immediate connection between
those two end points in the data set,
you can still just show those end points
and the connection in between for the
purpose of visual visualizing them. So
you don't need to add that extra edge
redundantly into your graph database.
And this the same was true for other
patterns. If you if you're looking for
certain patterns, consider only showing
the relevant parts of the patterns in
the visualization and do this via
projections from the database to the
visualization.
Many of you are using RDF triples or
label property graphs or either or and
they they are stored in a quite
different way. For example, on the top
uh left again we have we have a way of
storing information that you will find
it in ref triple stores mostly. So
there's the orange ones are the actual
entities and the uh the colorful ones
are like property nodes. So you have
basically have is orange is pink is
brown is green and so on. You could
represent the visualization like this,
but it's probably better in this case to
pull in those information and show it as
a property on the node visualization
itself. But you can also do it the other
way around. So if you have a label
property graph and there's a certain
attribute in all your data and you want
to like show that these are somehow
related because they share the same
attribute, introduce an artificial node
for the visualization and connect all
the nodes that have the same attribute
to this. uh uh attribute representation
node. Um the same works for edges. So
sometimes you have like almost fully
connected or in this case a bipartite
graph where all of the above nodes are
connected to all of the below nodes and
this for even for free nodes means you
have a lot of edges in your diagram.
Um so if they are if you don't care
about the different instances of these
edges but it's only about showing that
they are all connected to each other
consider using bundling as a technique.
So basically introducing a center node
in between to bundle the edges and thus
greatly unclutter your visualizations.
And of course all of these techniques
that I just showed you can combine them
freely and well make the best use of
them for your specific use case. Moving
on, once you have the projection from
your data to the structural information
in your diagram, you can employ layouts.
Automatic layouts is the the process of
arranging elements on your canvas in a
meaningful way. Not just in a way that
they are there and don't are overlap
free. That's that's a good thing to
start with. But try to encode relative
relevant information right into the
placement of the elements.
This way you can highlight certain
aspects in your data. things like flows
typically going from top to bottom or
left to right um or showing different uh
uh things like clusterings
and um all kinds of different aspects
that can be mapped to to different uh
sorry
can map to different layouts. Let's
let's see some examples.
Um, but before we get to this, first
let's talk about richer node designs. Of
course, nodes don't have to be just like
these boring boxes that we just saw
there. We can add information right in
the visualization that the user needs.
So if there's properties in your graph
that you want to show that are important
for users to see right from from the
beginning without having to interact
with the item or look the values up in a
in a database. Show this information
right in the visualization.
But be sure not to overload the the
visual uh the information. Don't produce
information overload. You can use
techniques like level of detail
rendering. So when you zoom out only the
most important information is shown and
once you zoom in more information gets
visible.
You can even go so far and add
interactivity within your note
visualizations. Show things like gauges
or progress bars or even UI elements
like buttons or tables if that's helpful
to the user right in the interface on
right inside the nodes or on the edges
even.
But it doesn't stop there. So you don't
have to focus on the nodes alone and on
the edges, but there's also the
background. The graphs are rendered onto
a canvas and it doesn't have to stay
blank. So you can use the canvas to add
additional information. A few obvious
ones you will find in here like we have
these these swim lanes at the bottom. So
if your nodes belong to different
categor categories, you can highlight
these categories by drawing some boxes
in the background or um it doesn't have
to be boxes like in the center where
there's just like these blobby features
in there. Or if if your data contains
geospatial information, put them on a
map if that's helpful to your users.
And if there are scalar values in there
that are important to for the
understanding, you can use things like
heat maps like in the top right to show
this information in a super convenient
way.
And last but not least, um add
interactivity to your apps to make
exploring your your diagrams enjoyable
and more efficient.
You can do things like offer search for
the user or dynamically filter down um
the view uh aggregate elements um enable
drilling down to so that they can
incrementally explore the results that
they see. You can use animations to
switch between different different
representations of the data or to show
different states of the data. So if your
if your graphs are basically annotated
with time data or or different snapshots
of different time stamps, you can
animate between them and help the user
understand how the graphs change.
So if you change the layout on the and
the design of the items, it really helps
the user to focus on different aspects.
You can even go so far and integrate uh
third party or live data sources and
make the diagram change live while
you're you're viewing it if that is one
of your use cases of course and and you
can turn it all around and even allow
the user to edit the data. So they can
interactively use the diagram to upload
the data, change the data in the
database or even create the database
from from scratch.
So um if you put all of these together,
we saw that this really made a big
impact for our customers. And just to
give you some examples, probably pretty
obvious by now to you. Um um so these
many of these are basically domain
specific knowledge graphs. Um supply
chain is a is a great examples. So you
can use this to optimize and find
bottlenecks or to simulate failures in
your supply chain or to analyze your
supply chain. It's super easy to to um
see the flow of your goods in your
supply in in visualizations like these.
And if you can uh even if your if these
bombs are are huge in size and there's
thousands of element in it that you can
use filtering and drill down techniques
to to get down to the core of the
problem.
The same works for financial works,
financial networks. I'm sure you heard
of fraud rings. I mean it's in the word
already. It says rings is obviously
something visual. So display them as as
rings. So if you want to identify fraud
patterns, you probably need some nice
algorithms to to find them. But showing
them means understanding them.
And obviously last example social
networks they can help you um
visualization can help you understand
the influence of or or better see how
the information flows through the social
networks to detect communities and so
on.
So let's take a look at some examples
that we built in the past some real
world. Those are those aren't customer
examples but those are tools that you
can use too. So, so you find them on our
website and you can uh those those are
free tools so you can just play around
with them and they they build on some of
these principles.
So for example, this is our u Jupyter
notebook widget um which allows you to
uh query a graph database or basically
any data source that has connected data
and then you can uh visualize the graph
right in your Jupyter notebooks and you
can apply different layouts to highlight
this different aspects. You can use data
binding to color the nodes uh to your
liking and bound to the data that that
they represent. Change the labels,
change the colors and thicknesses and so
on. And there's interactivity so you can
uh inspect the neighborhood
uh search the graph and so on. And
there's even the option to transform
your data so that you can make simple
transforms like introducing group nodes
that we have over here. Um making it
easier to to see groups of elements and
folding them away, aggregating them and
uh better understanding the data. Yeah.
One last example that also works is that
you can add a heat map to the to your
visualization and even put your data
onto a map. This is the Marvel Heroes in
London. And with in this case, we're
using some some cipher magic because
this querying a Neo Forj graph database
doesn't have to be, but this is one one
such example. we are actually uh
transforming the data from one form to
another to show a different aspect of
the graph in in a way that it's not
stored in the database. I won't go into
detail for this one so far. Let's go to
another example. This is uh from the
healthcare and patients data set that I
got from my friends at Neo Forj and this
is an application that we also host on
our website that helps you navigate your
Neo Forj graph database. And um what it
does it allows you to uh interactively
design your your notes and you can use
even genai to help you with the design.
So it will come up with a nice
presentation of the information right on
your notes that you can see them and you
don't have to manually design those
items
and it will allow you to incrementally
explore your data in using different
layouts using map visualizations and it
has this nifty u interactive tool that
I'm going to show in a second here
um which helps you to unclutter your
graphs which because typically if you of
geo data. Well, obviously they they
haven't been placed in a clever way.
They they just have been placed on the
map to to reflect the real world
placement. Um, so we have this this nice
uh tool in there that helps you
unclutter this information and uh see
the the actual items without
overlapping.
And yeah,
I'm quick.
Last example is um the uh uh another
example that that is actually my
favorite one. It shows how to navigate
the Marvel cinematic universe. It helps
you understand the movies and uh the the
how the the different characters in what
order they appear in in uh history time
in the Marvel Cinematic Universe. And it
helps you understand in what order you
should be watching those movies in order
not to spoil uh
the uh not in order to not to get
spoiled by any
wrong uh order of watching the movies.
Yeah, just a quick resolution recap
recap what we saw um are these three
tools on on the right hand side. Um they
are all powered by by our software
library. If you want to learn more, go
out to to our uh booth. Um I I'll skip
these quickly. Um so what we've seen is
in my humble opinion you get the best
visualizations if you create tailored
really use case specific solutions
because with those powerful situ uh
visualizations you get a more more
focused view on your data and with with
tailored items designs you can show
exactly the information that your users
require.
You can use meaningful layouts to encode
more information into the diagram
without really cluttering it. And with
great interactivity, it makes makes it
actually enjoyable and and feasible to
understand even the most complex
networks.
So now I'm ready to take your questions.
Thank you.
>> Yes. Thank you.
Okay. Any questions?
>> Yeah. Good.
>> Um, hi. Uh, what about edges? So when
you want to show edges and the amount of
connections relations is large and many
of the graphs that you showed are Doug
right a director and cyclic but when
they're not
>> um there is a balance between you know
when you want to lay out stuff in a way
that makes sense
>> or in a way that edges don't overlap and
you can just have edges direct or or
like the way you showed the chip I think
was to draw them around. Can you say
about about how to deal with with
overlapping edges?
Well, we we try hard to make our
algorithms in a way that they always
avoid overlaps. But this tends to uh
leave lead to very very large graphs if
you have lots of lots of edges. So the
best advice I can give you is don't show
them. Um make it interactive. um maybe
show that show a single edge over there,
show a number indicating the number of
edge edges it represents and then maybe
interactively show these or even show it
in a separate view. So um there's no
general good advice here, but um if you
try to keep it small um you're probably
going to be more happy.
Does it help?
Well, I can I have a question. Um, I
found it really fascinating and maybe we
can expand on that in our uh track
discussion tomorrow uh together with
everyone else from this track. Um, but I
was I was kind of seeing that what
you're doing is very similar to what I
was doing for the benefit of my
developers. So while I had an ontology,
I would also created an inference layer
that would summarize it a little bit or
you know kind of go across multiple hops
just to create a smaller version because
they needed it for example to serve APIs
to maybe serve a visualization or
something like that. Have you worked
with that that idea of you know an
ontology is one point of view and by
changing the ontology and knowing how to
change from one ontology to another you
can also um shorten and and support your
visualizations because maybe it's the
ontologist in me but I was just seeing
oh that's just another ontology for the
same data.
>> Exactly. Yeah. Um um uh as I as I try to
explain that um your data probably has a
like a fixed topology but for viewing
the data you should like try to apply
different ontologies on top of it and um
coming up with the right ontology is
something that probably only domain
expert or or the users of that data can
do. So it's really talking to the users
those who who will work with the
visualizations and understanding what
information they require and what is
just super. So um and this will allow
you to well come down with a with the
gist of the the the ontology that they
are working with. So most of time it's
just a subset. So but but that's the
beauty of it. If you once you have these
the ability to do these transformations
u from from your data into different u
well views on the data to to get
different perspectives you gain more
insights and that's that's the beauty of
>> um another thing maybe for those more
from the semantic web is is just basic
construct queries. So you're taking your
data and then you're creating construct
query to create another presentation of
it and it's still in its connected form.
And the same applies in cypher. You can
also create those those kind of um
shortcuts and so on.
>> Yeah. And you you can do this live
during just for the purpose purpose of
visualization. So basically create
throwaway data just for visualizing it.
Don't modify your database just for the
purpose of visualizing it. That's that's
not a good idea.
>> Yeah. And we have learned in this track
that um Bradley is not here but we've
learned in this track that not
necessarily graph isn't graph database.
So it can also be something that's
happening in a UI in a graph engine that
you're now saying that
>> um like kind of just doing those that
visual analysis and summarization.
>> Yeah,
>> exactly. Yeah, correct.
>> Any other questions? Everyone's eager to
go for a coffee break. Yeah. So um
great. Let's go on our coffee break and
we'll meet for the final three talks at
10 4. So, see you in 30 minutes.
>> Thank you.